who knew insurance agents lives were so
interesting when I went to the Jane Eyre
screening it was it like it's art house
theater and I'd start looking the list I
was like man they have a lot of really
obscure films here and there were some
foreign films I was like man I'm too
into the subtitle so I was looking
through the list and I found this one
that I was like hey I haven't seen that
it's not at me the theaters in my area
but this one had it so I decided to
check out Cedar Rapids it stars ed Helms
john c reilly and hache and some other
people it's about an insurance agent who
is sent to the Senate convention where
at various insurance agencies compete
for this big award and he's not prepared
at all for this because his coworker
died he's just taking his place all of a
sudden but he meets up with some other
agents and just some craziness and Sue's
basically for the first half or so this
fella is like where the laughs I mean
there were some chuckles but for the
most part this wasn't happening as the
film progresses though it got
increasingly more funny and I began to
become more attached to the characters
in this film john c reilly I've never
really been a huge fan of him I've
always just been like Oh easy there john
c reilly okay he's in the movie yet not
to Raleigh whatever but this movie he
was pretty funny in this one the first
line pretty much that his character says
I can't repeat it but it had me rolling
like it was so hilarious cuz the whole
movie I was just kind of enjoying it and
it was okay and then as soon as his
character came on
oh my word he was funny this character
played by Ed Helms he's a very very very
sheltered man and he's a very odd he
doesn't really know much about the world
he lives in his own little space
suddenly having to be sent out there
into the world he has to experience all
these various things and he has no
preparation for any of them
it can work for a lot of comedy first
half of the film I really wasn't a big
fan of his character because he was such
a tightwad you know but as the film
progressed he started to open up more as
a person and then I started to become
more attached to his character the
strength this movie is the characters
they're actually very entertaining and
and they seem real even though they're
so exaggerated there's a realness to the
characters and that's one of the things
I really appreciate about this film the
first maybe like fourth to half of the
film I just I wasn't finding that many
laughs this isn't like a fantastic
comedy that people will remember forever
but it's just it is a fun film you know
it's a good time waster to be honest I
would give cedar up as three out of four
stars if you can get past the beginning
it starts to get a lot more funny as it
goes and you start to grow more attached
to the characters